this is Startalk this is Brian here
you're Brian you their bartender did
anyone tell you that they're
constellations
yes that's what these are this is very
cool
I feel cosmic right now so I guess
there's a lion so which one is that
Leo's a lion come on now
very cool okay so I'm feeling very
cosmetic with for each one of our live
shows we've got to make a drink
yeah the fitting of the moment is a
beautiful beautiful and tonight's topic
is neuroscience and I'm trying to
connect it to the universe somehow
universe is really really cold
you know temperature it is three degrees
above absolute zero okay three actually
two point seven six but who's counting
okay three degrees so it's cold and we
got nervous on we're thinking brain
freeze a new drink called brain freeze
how about that
that works yeah yeah so I'm just trying
to think what of your your spirits are
normally like really cold I've seen I've
looked into some people's freezers and
there's a bottle of vodka in there I
think some longtime favor
yeah well so växjö turns out so alcohol
does not water obviously so it doesn't
freeze at 32 degrees it freezes way cold
okay
and so it'll work in any thermometer in
the world whereas mercury won't did you
know that if you put mercury in a
thermometer it freezes it 40 below so
mercury is no good at 41 degrees below
zero they can't tell you anything so you
got to put alcohol in it and color it so
they call it red typically so and so we
got frozen stuff in the universe so now
I want to drink and I'm thinking if it's
the brain the brain is like pinkish red
so what do you have this pinkish red you
could do a Cosmo
Cosmo Cosmo eyes pink is what gives it
that color well the combination from the
cranberry in a little bit of lime juice
uh-huh
that berries good okay like if we
squashed your brains out who resemble
this color is on the point okay so now I
want something it's got to be really
cold so I have to be I have a lot of ice
okay
especially chilled shakin shakin yeah
yeah shaken not stirred
yeah shaken you shake it and then you
pour in the glass yeah
happy eight chunks of ice huh nice guy
nice nice nice okay so would be this
plus watch this plus vodka vodka okay
juice
triple said we might make a little
different from a Cosmo so cuz it's gonna
be our drink for tonight okay brain
freeze so this you get the color you got
the booze and think you could that makes
it a little bit make a Pinker yes it
will rather than just pure red mm-hmm
cuz once you drain the blood of your
brains it's pink I've seen CSI I know
okay good so this will line up that'll
distinguish it from a Cosmo good so
what's the ratios of this let's try one
Nick one all right before we're done you
guys got to get these constellations
they're like real animals floating a
hook on the sky they've got it all
that's very cool not all the cost
they've got one two three four
they're 88 constellations I remember cuz
there's 88 keys on a piano but you have
to remember that there's 88 keys on a
piano to know that there's 88
constellations in the sky and there's a
dozen of them up there now I see I see
who's that that's Perseus holding this
bloody severed snake for hair head of
Medusa
I've got else we have here
I've got links that's good we've got
Virgo Virgo we've got oh
can a spent benetech see how you
pronounce that dude running dogs we got
them
oh here comes boo that's beautiful
that's brain color nice nice and Cole
nice let's check it out
there's a little bit of AC stuff a
minute yeah
brain freeze oh this is really nice and
cold
and it's very refreshing and uh I think
this work now they're no limes in the
universe just kind of think what else
can you put in this view hmm cherry
cherry cherry let's think about cherry
in the universe uh can't think of cherry
in the universe lemon you have an
umbrella you might want to shield
yourself from the luminosity of the
stars across the cosmos I can't think of
a lime orange how do you get a lime
orange of the universe
give me jeopardy music don't thank you
yeah everybody knows jeopardy music
think music boom boom par - citrus okay
I've got it
you're gonna give us a lime as an homage
to the fact that there are no green
stars in the universe there are orange
ones there are red ones
there are blue ones there are no green
stars so as you drink your brain freeze
thinking of the depths of cold in the
cosmos it's a requiem to the absence of
green stars you've got it okay thank you
Bryce yes Thank You Tuffy enjoy the
drink mm-hmm hmm brain freeze this is
really cold it's really cold
excellent this I don't he's he's giving
me this to try to help me in my day we
had to remember what the constellations
were nowadays people are pulling out
their iPad no I know what this guy is
look at this in my day we remembered
this stuff okay test me over here ready
okay should be Virgo right there on the
left snake
uh-oh drink oh of course Draco the
dragon of course leo the lion that
should be Perseus because he's holding
Medusa's head good snake for hair yeah
and oh we've got the guy holding the
staff that's like the thing that medical
doctors hold but they don't have a snake
wrapped around it but I think they
should Cephas Cephas yes he was a
medical doctor and normally the staff
has the snake around it which is the
symbol of the American Medical
Association
yeah liebe right there Libra has two
stars with the longest names of all the
stars in the night sky
Zubin LG Nubian Zubin s Kamali
that's crazy trivia for you okay what
else you got yeah yeah did can is Bennet
Venna teaching so can is is is like
canine dogs so it's the hunting dogs
which are these two dogs right here in
gray by the way none of these look like
what they do in the night sky I think
the Greeks there was opium or something
to help them imagine this none of them
look like any of us okay it's just it's
all pretend in fact we can do better
today I think there's consolation I
think look like the iPhone or the flat
panel TV it's not that matters in our
culture today the three day I'm telling
you you know you have the you know the
Prius you know those stars it would
serve our culture today better than
anything is up there now thank you all
again thanks for the drink Brian yeah
that's really good this is really good
I'm not sharing either
you